my name is Lee Chiu Lou and I walk on
front-end 3d graphics so the talk I'm
going to talk about is about some of the
new stuff of 3d graphics in front end
including some of the cool stuff like a
Swedish car pick up rendering support
and the NPR non-photorealistic graduate
support my name is is you - Lou I work
on front-end 3d graphics so today I'm
going to talk about a few new new stuff
we're currently working on and which is
the ru experimental stage and first
thing I want talk about is single path
steps peeling it's all about the 3d
transparent transparency rendering why
it is so expensive because of the order
the depths order of each pixel matters
to make it correct so some sort of
sorting has to be involved in and the
original version we use the BSP tree
what it does it divided the triangle
into very small enough pieces and then
sort them before we send it to renderer
and the downside of that is you can
manage their use a lot of memories and
of course CPU spins for that then we
come with multiple paths that really we
don't have to sort it a split and solid
what do we do is just doing multiple me
many joins them object many times so
each time it'll appear long perhaps
layer off and then put them together
after everything is done and the
downside of that is yeah you can see
that it you have to render the object
many times and now the new technology
allows to do that
single path step spinning so just random
ones pure everything and ran it and
that's down here are some of comparisons
over here and the numbers are collected
is on my notebook you can get a better
numbers I was desktop and I'm not going
to write it right now because the the
BSP tree my locked notable for a while
and we are short of time but I do want
to show you something
else if we pick up some random results
it is innate first and if we hold down
the Kentucky and try to interact with it
oh here it is we now support a 3d
stereoscopic of rendering and it is
building for Windows and you can rotate
it you can zoom in zoom out I see the
cursor there you can also translated it
as well you can minimize it so it just
do is just exact the same thing as in
the notebook and it is belong to the
graphics if you delete the graphics they
will be gone yeah so yeah so let me show
you a little bit more fancy example and
this is a volume rendering has some
lighting out and if we enlarge it that a
little bit sir can see that see that a
little bit better and we do the same
thing so it works with volume rendering
as well and if you have glasses you can
get a better depth possession perception
of this and if you want to try and there
are some classes of AI want to try in
person talk to me after the talk so so
here comes the next question how do we
can show different stereotypes the the
answer is pretty straightforward and
civil enough and if you go
- nvidia can do panel there are some
interface allow you to turn stereo on
and off you do a take away
yeah so and if your hardware support
there were a list of glasses you can
choose from and select that and you can
also turn it off and then we'll reload
that then in mathematica it would be
just just walk out as it expected them
okay let's move forward
[Music]
so next talking about an
non-photorealistic rendering what is NPR
in computer graphics scope they mainly
the rendering mainly have two directions
why is the photorealistic rendering to
make 3d graphics render as true as
possible that involves a lot of
complicated a lighting model and
typically why you use a lot of computer
power for that the other direction is
totally opposite is a random objects are
artistic style for example like a sketch
a water a color and the ink like a hand
joining something like that so we now
we're going to provide a collection of
NPR functionalities you can ignore this
because these were going to be have it
in beauty and you need you don't need to
worry about that and I listen did have
over here just just let you know how it
is implemented
and so for you to use it just used like
other directively you can use it
directly apply to any graphics for
example it is here let's make it a
bigger and they if you doing rotating it
just works as expected and everything's
running in real time and you can also
apply parameters to it like for example
here you can
they find the color of the outline and
it works as well if you want to apply to
something else like that this is a
different model and it just works so
which means you can use it just like
other normal derivatives and apply to
any graphics so tomb is it's put very
popular for for in a movie and it TV
industry and we I you yeah you can do it
in our 3d graphics as well and this is
the default color assigned and you can
you can you can also define the lighting
direction and also the tone colors
yourself and they're lucky to here you
can also yes specify lighted directions
so you can apply different stars to
different objects and it just works 2d
sketch and we now have some code to to
relate sketch pattern apply to fury
curve and so you can define the patterns
yourself and of course we can apply to
something any graphics defined these
this is another converter there
currently you need to convert it to a
fear to curve because theater curve
takes the the vertex texture coordinates
but we're going to move forward I'm
trying to add more to to the face face
based polygons and so that they can be
applied directly and yeah 3d sketch is a
little bit
mo Chiu key because evolve involves some
lighting computing to make it look at
better okay here it is so let's define
we have a some predefined features like
this called a pseudo sketch and you can
allow what do we do is apply this
directive to any function any sweidy
functions and like it does and but the
unity feeding a sketch style what what
are you sketch style it is basically I
mean true it just a texture has
different sketch lines there on the
bottom there's it's sicker so it can
terror it it can apply to different
lighting conditions so here is a example
I can see it will change when the
lighting direction changes and here's
another example in this example we apply
to two styles and this style it is let's
just it just a bunch of points and yeah
I can totally get a different feelings
of that and then we're going to provide
a bunch of collections of this sketch
pattern in the library in the future but
we were also opened up so that you can
specify yours and here's another example
apply to a sphere yeah so the idea is
just to make it a worker for any 3d
graphics so next you will notice that
the the NPR muscles and pure stuff is
there implemented with a keyword
recorder surface appearance what is
surface appearance it
something new feature we currently
working I tried to what it does it you
were exposed the customer low-level open
she had shadows to user and also to
developers so you can do a lot of
flexible things for example customize or
anything and it works with post 2d and
3d graphics and works on all platforms
including the software case and we are
following the GSL on 1.0 standard it is
guaranteed to work and here are some
examples of to the examples like this is
imager like edge detection of course we
can do a lot of fancy things with with
the building building functions but but
what else I want to say that here it is
the Agron is applying when it is
rendering so there's no memory cost
there is no CPU cost at all so it would
be very good if you want to do some
video processing and that there's a lot
of flexibility flexibility out there and
you can also do some gpgpu based on that
here it's example you are doing some
computing as you rendering scenes you
can do a lot of physics simulations it
is just fast and of course we have a
habit the true shaders is for 3d we are
already sure that and you can change
your the lighting directions the colors
so you can also try to combine the 2d
and 3d together what is what's the
benefit of that is you can do customer
right rendering for 3d and after that
you can do some pro poster processing on
that for example like a edge detection
or something yes okay here's a example
and
so this is customer airing this is a
postal processing so there's a lot of
flexibilities I also want to show we
have a very good messaging system so if
there's something wrong here it were the
message we're just pop up let me just
show you something a little quick yeah
you see okay something is wrong over
here it is directly from the low-level
hardware and we received it and then we
are Republic to user it is very useful
for debugging and beyond that we are
also having an object ecology our view
what is the gr view it allows you to use
low level OpenGL language directly in
Mathematica and so there's a full set of
140 OpenGL es2 functions implementing
plus a bunch of utility functions and
you can use all of the mathematical
matrix operation functions and the data
data set of that also also as a lot of
other function is available and also it
has same the the compiling link and
running time arrow for the back and here
is an example simple example what it
does
simply Navi that just defy a view point
and clear it with certain colors yeah
this is the error message from previous
shadow and this is barga and let's just
try to ignore that so if we're going to
change it a little bit different color
it just works and so so here you can
what you can do is it you can't define
the share to yourself of course
same as lucky that there the feature
with ocular before and the by that they
can do more things you can't define the
rendering pipe it's yourself you're
feeding in the data and these are
sequential OpenGL language and and then
you can do things like a current or
graphics language cannot do for example
viewing view it's simple enough but it
just works so you can also define your
own customized a renderer yourself so
here's the example here you defined
define all your own lighting or lighting
functions and their functionality also
you defined that the mouse interaction
yourself and you what do you do is feed
in data it just works and so so this
small piece of coded it is just the
small customized the renderer you define
yourself and if and you can be more
aggressive for example if we want to do
something reducing and you can do that
as well
this is small piece of example and so
you can yeah you can do a lot of cool
stuff so that's that's roughly my my
talk I want to say that these are
different directions we we are going and
definitely still is not that requires
more effort on that so please let us
know what you like better and we will
put more effort on it
you